hey Connor Brian here it doesn't get
more exciting than this I'm in Houston
for the third annual Super Bowl clueless
gamer what I want to do now is go to our
incomparable sideline reporter I hope
she can hear me now on the sidelines
erin andrews can you hear me yeah I got
you
oh thanks I am coming to you live from a
ballroom at the Houston Double Tree
Hotel where we are moments away from the
annual clueless gamer now I've covered a
lot of exciting sporting events and I
can say without a doubt this is not one
of them thank you Erin if you don't mind
I'm a little distracted you're always on
the sideline places like Green Bay and I
can see your breath I'm gonna have them
add that in post right now so we can see
your breath do you mind if we do that
why would you spend the money this year
I'm celebrating that the Superbowl is
inside you don't even have to see the
breath though it's pretty cool you can
see your breath isn't it better when you
see the breath reading snot too
you you talk to professional football
players all the time these are physical
specimens the finest in the world
be honest how do I rate this shirt
obviously has been tight enough I mean
we can see your nipples those weren't
even my nipples this shirt you can get
these at the gap now these shirts come
with nipples
[Music]
I'm gonna be honest I'm [ __ ] my
pants right now I'm here with Tom Brady
[Applause]
and I'm one of the biggest fans of yours
of all time Thanks such an honor to have
you here my first question I think is
the question is on everyone's lips just
bill belichick know that you're doing
this right now absolutely not okay I
cannot believe you'd be okay with this I
think he's gonna show up any minute now
like an angry dad and start yelling do
you think that might happen he doesn't
yell too much give me that look what
would the look be dis have discussed
bill don't ever give him a look of
disgust see anything like this
there's one area where I think that what
SEC doesn't know where he's doing I
think we should both chip in $60 and buy
him a new sweatshirt what do you say I
like his smile you like that style he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he looks like he
sleeps under a bridge just a little bit
yeah
would you ever go out on the town if
you've got a fifth ring and wear all
five on your hand at the same time would
you never do that I don't think I've
ever worn one period yeah I would wear
all of them on different parts of my
body at different times I would be so
proud I can't what do you do do you just
keep them on a shelf something like in a
safe and they just sit there then you
pull them out you know and you do what
what do you do you like Gollum with the
ring you whip it out I don't whip it out
okay we're gonna take that out of
context
we're both icons in Massachusetts we
both risen to the very top of our
profession why are you laughing it's so
rude that is so rude
do you play video games a little bit
yeah a little bit
this game is called for honor are you as
competitive playing video games as you
are playing football
yeah I've broken a lot of remotes in my
day and broken a lot of TVs so so you're
intense this could get really intense
maybe let's start playing the game what
do you say let's get my colleague in
here Aaron Blair Aaron do you mind
coming in and telling Tom and I a little
bit about the game
sure hey how's it going no no you don't
have to initiate conversation oh I'm
sorry you guys are gonna be going a
head-to-head against each other there's
a yeah basically the bottom or samurai
all group the top or Valkyrie oh that's
it oh you chose Valkyrie huh woman yeah
she's the woman oh she's a fierce
warrior you got a problem with that I
have no problem that I just saw you with
breasts and I got both aroused and upset
I don't but I like it I like it a lot
I'm having trouble looking I'm having
troubles just looking around a person
wrong way okay now I'm coming towards
you Tom there you go you're headed
towards I'm chasing Tom Brady I'm
chasing Tom Brady who is not engaging me
now wait
which I've never seen before but I just
feel what I just do one you just knock
Tom Brady out the breeze anything no I
didn't know you could just fall are you
okay
on - there we go
you seem angry Oh hold it there you go
there you go right in the throat Oh get
them I'm a fan oh no in the corner Oh No
how many times I gotta hit this guy ah
God dang it tough
thank you Tom Brady Tom thank you
how did that feel you you know I won
that 21 we all saw that okay should we
go for round three this decides it you
ready Tom I'm yeah oh there you go
[Music]
it's the problem what's the problem yeah
you just made a fool out of me Tom
you know what really hurts when you do
that by the way well that's exciting
we've just been joined from the Atlanta
Falcons by Dwight Freeney Dwight thanks
for being here Tom Grady
four times don't you think you owe him
an apology
absolutely nods yes how many times he
beat us and throwing touchdowns
what apologize to me a quarterbacks
trying to do his job he's trying to get
something done you come running up at
him you tackle him you knock him to the
ground
if I did that at your workplace that
would be rude and he throws the ball too
quick I can't get there
I'd like a quick apology that's all I'm
just a quick one just as long as we both
say the same Tom we're okay on three all
right
one two three
[Applause]
what are you gonna do Dwight you're the
Peacekeeper tired tired you're working
through a lot of stuff - I know you're
working through a lot all right we
retire this remote I yeah so coffee yes
[Applause]
the Bronk Bronk Kowski Ron Catania
success is six-six what do you weigh
true 69 to 69 what did you have for
breakfast like a Buick what do you do
I got you a present - Conan I was trying
to do with something today this is
called ice shaker it says it's Amish man
says Conan right there honest is Shawna
what's the brand name drunk I shake I
shake check it out check it out I'm 78
years old that's pretty good put it on
the ticker okay we're doing a kind of
television that no one wants to see yes
that was a big hairy bush Ron Ron you
brought some friends with you let's get
him in here let's make this even more
interesting mother three two one oh you
brought a friend
Marshawn Lynch our shot you're losing
your pants I'm not going
you can't I'm sorry man this hombre D
has chosen who made over through honk
that's marshawn's hometown the Raiders
and Marchand who are you gonna face oh I
was looking for somebody with some
melody but he might be one of them one
yeah big out matters they probably
wanted one so they had to cover they ass
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what might be the most important award
of his life ultimate Blademaster extreme
trophy that is absolutely beautiful I'm
gonna accept this on behalf of my team
back here okay so you more or less got
rid of that as quickly as you could and
guess what we thought of Dwight we
thought of you too you get an I played
too
[Applause]
that is they'll receive with trophies
even when I'm the tired
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you